El vídeo de hoy ha sido posible gracias a
Masterworks.
Hay una palabra que seguro no dejas de oír
en los últimos meses: inflación.
Los bancos centrales están imprimiendo dinero
como si no hubiera mañana lo que, por ejemplo,
ha provocado en enero de 2022 un aumento interanual
del 7% en los precios de Estados Unidos, los
niveles más altos en 39 años.
Hasta ahora para cubrirse contra la inflación
lo habitual era invertir en oro, acciones
o incluso inmuebles.
Pero existen nuevas alternativas y queremos
enseñaros una súper interesante: el mercado
del arte.
El mercado del arte es gigantesco, se estima
que el total de activos ronda los $1.7 billones
y Deloitte calcula que puede crecer otros
$900 mil millones para 2026.
Además, como podéis ver en pantalla, su
rentabilidad no ha sido nada desdeñable:
De hecho, entre las grandes fortunas, es una
apuesta muy habitual.
Ahí está el caso de la familia Rockefeller,
que a lo largo de los años fue acumulando
una de las mayores colecciones de obras de
arte de la historia, y que se vendieron en
2018 por una astronómica cifra de 835 millones
de dólares.
Vale, seguro que estaréis pensando, pero
a ver chicos, ¿a mí qué me importa esto?
Cómo voy a diversificar mi cartera con una
obra de Basquiat o de Warhol, que cuestan
millones de dólares, eso está totalmente
fuera de mis posibilidades.
Eso solo pueden hacerlo los billonarios.
Pues…
Esperad porque aquí es donde entra Masterworks.
Masterworks tiene como misión que cualquier
persona pueda invertir en grandes obras de
arte a través de pequeñas participaciones.
Con Masterworks puedes ser copropietario de
piezas de arte exclusivas que contribuyan
a cuidarte de la inflación; y ojo, incluso
quien sabe, poder llegar a obtener una buena
rentabilidad.
Por ejemplo, los inversores que compraron
la Mona Lisa de Banksy con Masterworks consiguieron
un rendimiento anualizado del 32%.
¿Estaremos acaso ante una nueva forma de
inversión alternativa para diversificar y
optimizar nuestras carteras?
Os dejamos un link a Masterworks en la descripción,
accediendo a través de él podréis saltaros
la waitlist para registraros.
Y como siempre, en todo lo relacionado con
la inversión: mucha cabeza.
No existe nada libre de riesgos.
Y ahora sí, empecemos con nuestro vídeo
de hoy.
Os lanzo una pregunta: ¿alguna vez os habéis
preguntado si a Europa le conviene más tener
la protección militar de la OTAN o crear
su propio ejército europeo?
[Sí, ya sé que pueden ser cuestiones compatibles.
Pero, si tuvierais que escoger, ¿por cuál
de las dos opciones os decantaríais?]
En este vídeo nos vamos a ocupar de un tema
con importantes implicaciones, especialmente
si tenemos en cuenta los recientes acontecimientos
en la frontera entre Polonia y Bielorrusia;
Y sobre todo la crisis político-militar entre
Ucrania y Rusia.
Una frontera donde las fuerzas rusas han pasado
meses haciendo más y más cálculos sobre
una posible invasión.
Una invasión que si bien no implica en absoluto
a ningún país de la OTAN, es vista por muchos
expertos en seguridad, así como por los propios
países bálticos, como la antesala, el ensayo
de lo que un buen día podría llegar a suceder,
por ejemplo, en Estonia, Letonia o Lituania.
Así que, teniendo todo esto en cuenta, ¿os
apetece saber más sobre la defensa de Europa?
¿Qué le conviene más a los miembros de
la Unión Europea, la OTAN o un nuevo ejército
europeo desarrollado completamente al margen
de Estados Unidos?
¿Cuál de las dos opciones garantiza mejor
los intereses y la seguridad de los países
comunitarios?
Pues bien, respondamos a todas estas preguntas.
Atentos.
¿Cómo se puede garantizar la seguridad de
Europa?
Esta es la pregunta.
Pero, antes de que empecemos a meternos de
lleno en la cuestión de si OTAN sí u OTAN
no, ejército europeo sí o ejército europeo
no, veamos brevemente qué es exactamente
la OTAN y en qué consiste.
Porque, seguro, seguro que la inmensa mayoría
de vosotros lo sabéis, pero puede que alguno
veáis toda esta cuestión con cierta distancia.
(La OTAN, la Organización del Tratado del
Atlántico Norte, es una organización militar
internacional cuyo objetivo pasa por garantizar
la defensa colectiva de los países miembros.
Fue creada en 1949 en las fases iniciales
de la Guerra Fría y el enfrentamiento a cara
de perro entre Occidente y la Unión Soviética.
En aquel momento, y durante las cuatro décadas
posteriores, la amenaza de terminar en guerra
o de sufrir un ataque soviético sobre la
Europa Occidental era muy real.
Precisamente por eso se decidió que la única
manera de disuadir al enemigo era unir fuerzas
entre los países europeos pro-occidente y
Estados Unidos.
La clave básica de este modelo es que si
algún enemigo ataca a cualquiera de los países
miembros de la OTAN, el resto se comprometen
a asistirles militarmente, prestarles ayuda
e incluso intervenir directamente.
Un modelo que ha sobrevivido en el tiempo
pero que ha visto cambiar el nombre de su
principal adversario: de la Unión Soviética
a Rusia.)
Ahora bien, no se trata sólo de un compromiso
de defensa mutua.
La OTAN también busca mejorar la modernización,
la coordinación y la integración de los
diferentes ejércitos para llegado el caso
poder luchar juntos.
Hablamos de un paraguas de seguridad completo:
toma de decisiones, asunción de compromisos
e incluso despliegue de tropas para reforzar
la seguridad de los aliados más débiles.
Esto es, por ejemplo, lo que ocurre con las
fuerzas que muchos países miembros de esta
alianza envían a los países bálticos.
También podríamos englobar aquí los despliegues
permanentes o rotatorios de fuerzas de Estados
Unidos en países miembros de la alianza.
En términos de seguridad, suena bien, ¿Verdad?
Integración, coordinación y el apoyo de
la mayor superpotencia del mundo.
Si hablamos de seguridad, ¿Qué más se puede
pedir?
Pues, sin embargo, amigos hay un pequeño
problema: con el paso de los años la OTAN
parece haberse hecho menos popular entre las
viejas potencias de la Europa Occidental.
Por ejemplo, prestad mucha atención a estas
declaraciones del presidente francés sobre
la crisis con Rusia.
("Es bueno que los europeos y los Estados
Unidos se coordinen, pero es necesario que
los europeos lleven a cabo su propio diálogo".
- Emmanuel Macron, presidente de Francia ante
el Parlamento Europeo)
Sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Básicamente lo que Macron pide es que la
política de seguridad de Europa sea completamente
independiente a la de Estados Unidos.
Qué Bruselas lleve a cabo sus negociaciones,
acuerdos y compromisos de forma completamente
independiente a Washington incluso en casos
de conflicto.
Lo que, si nos paramos a pensarlo, supone
romper el frente común, el eje atlántico,
la idea que subyace a la propia OTAN.
Y evidentemente para poder ser independiente
en materia de seguridad necesitas tener tus
propias capacidades militares.
[Claro, digo yo no vas a querer tomar tu las
decisiones mientras te cubres con los soldados
de otros..]
Queridos amigos, amigas, no es en absoluto
frecuente que un líder europeo con tanto
peso hable con semejante grado de “OTAN-escepticismo”.
De hecho, escuchando a Macron casi podríamos
llegar a pensar, no sé, que Vladimir Putin
estuvo a puntito de salirse con la suya: fracturar
la OTAN a golpe de amenaza.
[Por cierto, si queréis saber más detalles
sobre cómo ha ido cambiando la OTAN con el
paso del tiempo y sobre cómo funciona no
os podéis perder este vídeo.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.
(EL GUARDIÁN DE EUROPA)
A ver, ¿Os habéis preguntado alguna vez
cómo es la defensa de Europa, el sistema
actual, y qué papel juega Estados Unidos
en ella?
Pues bien, los ejércitos pertenecientes a
la OTAN cuentan con cientos y cientos de miles
de soldados en la vieja europea.
Por supuesto, la inmensa mayor parte de ellos
pertenecen, lógicamente, a los propios países
europeos.
Hablamos, sin embargo, de ejércitos que suelen
tener muchísimas carencias, particularmente
si nos referimos a sus capacidades de despliegue.
Algo que limita mucho su operativa.
Y esto no lo decimos nosotros, sino la propia
Unión Europea en su borrador para crear una
fuerza militar europea de respuesta rápida.
(“Necesitamos ser capaces de responder a
amenazas inminentes o reaccionar rápido a
situaciones de crisis, por ejemplo un rescate
y una misión de evacuación, o una operación
de estabilización en un entorno hostil.”
- Borrador de Strategic Compass de la UE)
[Evidentemente lo plantea como objetivo porque
la UE es consciente de que hoy por hoy sus
países europeos no tienen esa capacidad.]
El caso es que por todas estas carencias,
cada vez que se eleva la tensión en el este
de Europa, como por ejemplo ocurrió tras
la invasión y posterior anexión de Crimea
por parte de Rusia, Estados Unidos se ve obligado
a mover ficha y reforzar su presencia en el
continente.
La potencia norteamericana es uno de los pocos
miembros, tal vez junto al Reino Unido y quizás
Francia que puede realizar despliegues muy
rápidos.
De hecho, los países europeos tienen unas
capacidades tan limitadas que, por sí mismo,
sin el apoyo y la asistencia norteamericana,
es muy probable que no pudieran garantizar
por sí mismos la propia seguridad de todos
los países miembros.
Tanto es así que la Administración de Barack
Obama creó en 2014 la iniciativa de defensa
europea, conocida como EDI por sus siglas
en inglés.
(La iniciativa respondía a un viejo reclamo
de los países de Europa del Este.
Con ella se quiso reforzar la contribución
norteamericana a la seguridad europea.
Para lograr este objetivo, la iniciativa planteaba
incrementar las fuerzas desplegadas en países
considerados de primera línea como Estonia,
Letonia, Lituania o Polonia.
También, aumentar el presupuesto destinado
a realizar ejercicios militares multinacionales
y mejorar las infraestructuras claves para
la disuasión.
En la práctica el programa le ha costado
a los norteamericanos cerca de 25 mil millones
de dólares entre los años 2016 y 2021.
Toda una muestra de compromiso por parte del
Tio Sam.)
Gracias a la Iniciativa de Defensa Europea,
Estados Unidos ha desplegado cazas F-15 y
F-16 en Reino Unido e Italia.
Y también ha incrementado el número de tropas
desplegadas en Polonia y en los países bálticos.
Ahora bien, la pregunta es: ¿es este refuerzo
suficiente para proteger Europa de una agresión
externa?
Pues…Sí y no al mismo tiempo.
Sí, porque gracias a estos despliegues cualquier
agresión pasa por poner en jaque a los propios
Estados Unidos, no solo por la disuasión
general que supone de por sí el compromiso
de seguridad mutua sino también por tener
que atacar a efectivos norteamericanos..
Y eso, amigos, son palabras mayores.
Es lo que podríamos llamar disuasión de
no retorno.
Pero, por otro lado, los expertos en estrategia
militar parecen tener algo muy pero que muy
claro:
Las 3 repúblicas Bálticas - que además
cuentan con una importante minoría rusa entre
su población - son el gran talón de Aquiles
de la OTAN.
Seamos claros: de acuerdo a los estudios y
simulaciones realizadas, Rusia podría alcanzar
las capitales bálticas - Tallín, Riga y
Vilnius - en un máximo de 60 días.
Es decir - y ojo porque esta es una cuestión
vital en el debate del ejército europeo - el
discurso de disuasión general que es capaz
de abanderar la OTAN es la única protección
real que en la práctica estos países tienen
contra una invasión o un ataque de guerra
híbrida.
Eso es quizás lo que explique noticias como
esta:
(Kallas [PM de Estonia] pide más tropas de
EE.UU. en los Bálticos - Postimees)
(El Reino Unido se plantea duplicar la presencia
de tropas en Estonia - Postimees)La pregunta
es, ¿Por qué Estonia le pide a Estados Unidos
y al Reino Unido más tropas y no hace lo
mismo con países europeos aliados que están
mucho más cerca?
FPues básicamente lo hacen por una cuestión
de capacidad y disuasión.
Al final, el gran activo que tiene la OTAN
y que, por ejemplo, nunca tendría una organización
de seguridad estrictamente de la Unión Europea,
es que detrás de ella está Estados Unidos
y en menor medida también Reino Unido.
La mayor y una de las mayores potencias militares
del mundo.
Tampoco tendría esta misma organización
las capacidades de combate y despliegue rápido
que ahora los Estados Unidos le aportan a
la OTAN.
Y esto es algo que nos lleva directamente
a otro de los grandes temas: la pasta.
Como todos sabéis en la OTAN existe una directriz
de gasto del 2% del PIB.
Sin embargo, salvo Estados Unidos, el Reino
Unido, las repúblicas bálticas, Polonia
y alguna que otra excepción la inmensa mayor
parte de los miembros del club atlántico
no cumplen esa directriz.
Y la pregunta es: ¿Estarían dispuestos a
cambiar su asignación de fondos públicos
e incrementar sus presupuestos militares?
Pues…
Visto lo visto todo parece apuntar a que no.
Y, ojo, porque no se trata sólo del volumen
de gasto sino también de su composición.
Por ejemplo, actualmente los países europeos
de la OTAN gastan en defensa prácticamente
lo mismo que China, y mucho, muchísimo más
que Rusia.
El problema no es el volumen de gasto sino
sobre todo su composición: por ejemplo, gastar
mucho en personal y poco en equipos.
De esta forma, mientras que por ejemplo en
Estados Unidos destina el 30% de su presupuesto
militar a inversión en nuevos equipos y tecnologías,
en el caso de los ejércitos europeos esta
cifra es mucho más baja.
La media de los últimos 6 años no llega
al 20%.
En definitiva, que hoy por hoy los ejércitos
de los países de la Unión Europea, salvo
alguna honrosa excepción, no tienen capacidad
por sí mismos para ser considerados como
un actor relevante, incluso si los analizamos
de forma conjunta.
Y claro, sin unas fuerzas armadas efectivas
y sin ser capaces de garantizar ni siquiera
la seguridad en la Europa continental, ¿Cómo
demonios vas a ser capaz de tener una política
de seguridad totalmente independiente?
¿Cómo vas a establecer un discurso disuasorio
eficaz?
Y de otras cuestiones como la dependencia
energética, ya ni hablemos.
Ahora bien, ¿Solucionarían todos estos problemas
la creación de una estructura militar de
defensa estrictamente europea como parece
querer plantear Macron?
¿Tiene acaso la culpa la OTAN del poco compromiso
manifestado por muchos de sus países miembros?
Estas son las preguntas clave en toda esta
historia.
Atentos.
(LA ILUSIÓN DE LA AUTODEFENSA)
¿Por qué Macron pide que Europa vaya por
libre?
¿Necesita realmente la Unión Europea avanzar
en estructuras militares a parte de la OTAN?
¿Estaría acaso mejor defendida Europa si
solo dependiera de sus propios recursos y
prescindiera de Estados Unidos?
Pues veréis, en este caso las respuestas
suelen tener casi siempre un corte político.
La presidencia de Donald Trump en Estados
Unidos, por ejemplo, fue, de hecho, gasolina
para el sentimiento de querer apostar el futuro
de la seguridad a unas auténticas fuerzas
armadas europeas.
¿Por qué?
Bueno, digamos que Trump no fue el tipo más
amistoso con la OTAN y los países europeos.
(Trump discutió sacar a EE.UU. de la OTAN,
según asesores en medio de nuevas preocupaciones
sobre Rusia - The New York Times)
(“No está bien que se aprovechen en la
OTAN y luego que se aprovechen en el comercio,
y eso es lo que sucede.
No podemos permitir que eso suceda.”
- Donald Trump)
(EE.UU. retirará alrededor de 12.000 soldados
de Alemania pero casi la mitad se quedarán
en Europa - Reuters)
Al final nada de esto sucedió, pero las palabras
rara vez son neutrales.
Sea como sea, la idea de poner en marcha un
ejército europeo o una estructura de coordinación,
decisión y operaciones sin Estados Unidos,
Reino Unido y Canadá, no es algo nuevo.
Pero, gracias a Trump y quizás a la creciente
dependencia energética de Rusia, sí que
nos hemos encontrado con un nuevo fervor.
Claro que sobre todo esto ya se han producido
muchos intentos y muchos fracasos de la Unión
Europea.
Nunca se ha conseguido que las cosas funcionen
bien.
S(Ahí tenemos, por ejemplo, el caso de los
Eurocorps, que con hasta 60.000 efectivos
y 11 estados participantes son un cuerpo militar
establecido en 1992 y sirve fundamentalmente
de apoyo para misiones de paz o de estabilización
de la ONU, la OTAN y la OSCE.
También hay otros ejemplos como la Fuerza
de Gendarmería Europea, que es una especie
de policía europea con estatus militar que
apenas cuenta con unas 2.000 unidades adscritas.
O la Fuerza Operativa Rápida Europea, que
desde 2012 ya no existe, y que se suponía
iba a ser una pequeña fuerza de despliegue
rápido capaz de maniobrar en menos cinco
días para contribuir a misiones humanitarias
o misiones de paz.
Hoy, todos estos cuerpos, y alguno más adicional,
están enmarcados dentro de la Cooperación
Permanente Estructurada, conocida como PESCO,
que busca la integración estructural de las
fuerzas armadas de los 25 estados miembros
que están adscritos.)
¿Podría cambiar esta realidad en el futuro?
Pues…Podría ser…
Pero los primeros en desconfiar de toda esta
historia son los países del centro y el este
de Europa.
Los antiguos miembros del Pacto de Varsovia.
Países como Polonia, las Repúblicas Bálticas,
Rumania, Bulgaria o Eslovaquia se sienten
mucho más seguros con Washington que con
Bruselas.
A todos los niveles.
La crisis con Ucrania ha sido un buen ejemplo
de ello.
Mientras París y Berlín querían desarrollar
negociaciones propias con Putin, la mayoría
de países del este de Europa pedían dos
cosas:
Una voz única conjunta de la OTAN
Y un mayor despliegue de tropas de Estados
Unidos.
C5(“Es muy importante que la OTAN dé una
respuesta común [a la tensión actual]”.
General Rajmund Andrzejczak, Jefe del Estado
Mayor de las Fuerzas Armadas de Polonia)
De hecho, esto podría ser un importante elemento
de fractura, una grieta más, si Francia y
Alemania siguieran empecinados en ir por libre.
Claro que los recientes acontecimientos con
Rusia parecen haber conseguido todo lo contrario
a lo pretendido por Macron y también por
Vladimir Putin:
La crisis en Ucrania ha rejuvenecido a la
Organización del Tratado del Atlántico Norte,
que ha podido mostrar su importancia como
hacía décadas no ocurría.
Además, mejorar la coordinación y la interoperabilidad
de los ejércitos europeos es algo deseable,
pero intentar desarrollar una estructura que
termine rozando con la alianza atlántica
puede ser una idea terrible.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Cómo crees que Europa estaría mejor defendida,
con un ejército europeo o con la OTAN a través
del paraguas de Washington?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí abajo, en los comentarios.
Y recuerda, si te ha gustado este vídeo no
olvides darle like y suscribirte a nuestro
canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.